hey guys welcome to maxtec and as you
know we've been testing out samsung's
brand new galaxy tab s8 ultra which is a
massive beast of a tablet and a lot of
you guys were asking us about the gaming
performance and fps so that is exactly
what we're going to figure out in this
video comparing it to the 12.9 inch m1
ipad pro so i'm going to run a bunch of
games and test out the fps on both the
ipad and the new tab s8 ultra and give
you guys my thoughts on the general
experience of gaming and the fps latency
different stuff like that and to do that
i have a macbook right here with perf
dog pre-loaded as you can see this
basically gives you real-time data on
the fps and a bunch of different metrics
it gives you a full report so i'm going
to use that to see which ipad is
basically the best gaming tablet in 2022
let's jump right into it for now let's
put the ipad pro over to the side
grab the crazy large
tab s8 ultra and the first thing i am
noticing so far is that you are getting
like some weird anti-aliasing
glitchy lines and stuff on here and i
think it's because this is such a
massive display and some android games
and apps aren't that well optimized with
the aspect ratio but let's go ahead and
get into the graphics settings as you
can see i have it fully maxed out very
high in max i've turned on anti-aliasing
and some of these extra features let's
just turn all of those on right there
and for multiplayer let's turn those on
bloom everything there you go and let's
go ahead and jump into a game and now
that we're in i'm gonna hit record fps
right here and we should be
tracking just fine first things first
this is a heavy tablet it's just so
massive it's kind of hard to hold so you
probably want to grab a controller if
you're actually planning on gaming with
this and because the display is so huge
the graphics quality is pretty terrible
like oh it's not good i don't know if
this app is like completely not
optimized for tablets which the nice
thing about the ipads
is that they are fully optimized
as ipad apps so far fps is looking good
we do see some minor dips right there
but
pretty solid everything feels smooth
here too so no issues man it's just hard
to like hold this
control this thing
all right
oh dude you gotta stretch your entire
hand man if you got small hands
don't play like this okay we won let's
see four and a half minutes yeah no
issues with cod oh it looks like it goes
down to 30 in the menus so it did kind
of mess at the end alright so because
this was so easy we're just gonna leave
it at that one match it was able to
handle 60 fps just fine so let's move
over to the ipad pro and see how that
performs and here we are on the ipad pro
and it instantly feels smaller and
lighter easier to control and use
so let's go ahead and check out those
graphics settings let's see so it lets
you do ultra interestingly so let's try
that out let's try the ultra quality and
for some reason it doesn't let me turn
any of this other stuff on so i'm just
gonna turn on everything that i can
ultra
multiplayer only it looks like so let's
test that out and get into a game
whoa speakers i noticed the speakers are
like boomier a little bit bassier that's
what i like about the ipad pro alright
and here we go now that we're in a game
i've started the recording look at that
120 fps guys that is what i like to see
oh that's smooth
oh i instantly feel that 120.
super super smooth compared to the tab
oh it almost like gives you a
competitive advantage plus it's easier
to control but man this is smooth
looking at it it's going down a little
bit but it's staying like above 100 i'd
be happy as long as it stays over 60
better than the tab but man it's nice
that this actually supports 120fps this
looks good sounds good speakers are
great the quality isn't super good but
i'm definitely not noticing aliasing
like i was oh but the difference is
going to 120 fps i mean that by itself
and the weird thing is the tab said like
max frame rate like it seems like it
should be a lot it supports 120 but only
on the ipad pro are you getting this
whoa
come on fire oh please please please
please please oh come on the ipad pro
wins easily for cod mobile just because
you can't get 120 fps on that tab and
now before we move on to the next game
let's actually look over here to the
perf dog statistics and analytics of
both games so right here first of all we
have the tab s8 ultra so it looks like
an average of 58 fps and that's because
it included a little bit at the end
where it got out of the game to the
lobby so basically perfect 60 fps and in
terms of the cpu usage it's still pretty
low only 20 average usage so no big deal
there
and now moving over to the ipad pro
116.8 fps also including at the end
right there you see a huge drop off
going down to 30 but man
very smooth and consistent 120 fps which
is very impressive
and the cpu usage whoa only nine percent
to get 120fps that's really impressive
so
definitely for cod mobile the ipad pro
wins and let's move on to the next game
before i go ahead and jump into pokemon
unite i did notice in my top camera that
you can see these lines kind of flowing
down the display and that's because of
the pwm flicker rate that controls the
oled brightness and a lot of people have
been complaining about this because it
hurts some people's eyes whoever is
sensitive to it now i am not but this
could bug you which i don't think the
ipad pro has this issue because it's
mini led instead of oled now
unfortunately it made me do the tutorial
which sucks but at least we can get a
good idea of the performance actually
let's go into here
got the frame rate at high
brightness recommended so we got
everything
under control and now let's test out the
uh fps so far it looks like we're
getting perfect 60 fps just like before
give us the goals man give us the goals
all right and there you go we have
finished
let's stop that recording
and perfect 60 fps no issues at all and
i'd say the controls are better in
pokemon unite and yeah i think the
graphics are optimized they look a lot
better too and now on the ipad pro you
can see we don't have those lines and we
actually have a lot more settings here
we have frame rate high graphics quality
highest for some reason we didn't have
those on the tab s8
but it's all turned up to the max so
let's go ahead and get into a match all
right now that we're in let's go ahead
screen record let's start that for some
reason it shows that we're at
60 fps but over here in my system it
says 120 which is interesting
oh
what okay so it's weird it's recording
as 120 fps but this only shows 60 so i
wonder what's going on i mean looking at
the animations they seem very quick
definitely no issues at all
oh he just deleted me
are you serious okay i'm gonna look very
closely to see if i can tell if it's 120
or not all right so i'm moving back and
forth
and it's definitely super smooth but i
don't know if it's actually 120 ps i
think it actually is
capping it at 60 for some reason which
is weird but it's definitely incredibly
smooth so i'd say
between both the ipad and the tab s8
plus if this is in fact capped to 60
then the gameplay experience is
basically the same except it's a little
bit more immersive on the tab s8 ultra
but it is a little bit harder to control
and now comparing the actual stats
between the two here we have the tab s8
ultra which shows 59.1 fps
compared to 118 but that's actually not
true i think it was capped at 60. it was
incredibly smooth but i think it was
capped at 60 let's compare the cpu usage
5.6 cpu usage on the ipad pro compared
to
average of 13
so that's very interesting and now
before we get into gentian impact i do
want to play wild rift and man
i could feel how much heavier this thing
is compared to the ipad pro and one
thing i really don't like is that when
you're holding this thing man you block
the speaker grills right here and right
here because you're just trying to hold
all that weight so like the volume
gets cut in half
it's a little bit annoying now in the
graphics settings unfortunately i went
to custom and it does not let you do 90
or 120 fps that really sucks so we're
going to keep it at 60 and just have
super high
graphics quality let's change the
effects to high as well
and make sure all this stuff
is set high let's go ahead and play some
aram and now this is a huge difference
this game looks like it's actually
optimized for this large display and
i've got to say this looks amazing
compared to cod mobile which looked
terrible on this large over 14 inch
display so i'm happy about this now that
we're in the game let's go ahead start
it we're looking at 60 fps even so
graphics quality definitely looks great
man you definitely get tired holding
this thing it's just so huge but perfect
60 right here this game is very well
optimized
boom
boom
so far so good i haven't seen it drop
from 60 no issues as as you'd expect i
mean this is an expensive tablet
that's for sure but man i love this
massive display everything looks so good
so bright even though the actual maximum
brightness
isn't nowhere as near as the ipad pro
with that mini led
it's still bright enough
for gaming so far league of legends wild
rift
excellent gaming experience on this
thing absolutely excellent guys i think
we won the game yeah
we actually
was so crazy
good job dudes yes
we did it there you go let me pause that
right there
stop recording that was an awesome
experience on this thing
this display is so massive and i love
how league is actually optimized
everything looks good there's no
anti-aliasing issues like look at that
that looks amazing now back on the m1
ipad pro in the graphics settings of
wild rift yes you get 120 fps as an
option this is what you want in a
competitive game like league of legends
wild rift so it doesn't let you turn the
graphics quality as high but 120fps is
more important and the resolution is at
high as well so let's go ahead and jump
into a match and i am noticing more boom
like more bass from the speakers once
again guys i think the speakers on this
thing i don't know they're just better
than the tap once again we're sitting at
around 120 fps maybe down to 117 at
times but still good
oh
i gotta watch out
oh
of course bro come on all right solid
120 so far i mean this is a huge deal
like look at that insanely smooth fps is
such a big deal for competitive games
like this solid 120. actually sometimes
i do see it go down a little bit yeah
sometimes it does go down to 90 it's at
113 right now so it is not solid 120. it
looks like for some reason in uh perfdog
it's showing it almost always as 120
which is really weird i don't know why
it does that for example right now i'm
looking at around 116 fourteen fps but
here it's almost always at 120 so i
don't think we can rely on birthdawg not
sure what's going on with it but yep
108. 109 still better than 60 though but
hey oh 90 right there interesting it's
not always solid 120.
you guys said that was clean bro
all right there you go that was an
excellent gaming experience
going at mostly 120 fps a lot of times
it would go down to 115 when it would
dip and it did go as low as 90 but of
course that is all much better than
being capped at 60 fps like we had on
the galaxy tab s8 ultra and now we
finally have genshin impact the game
that you guys have been waiting for on
the galaxy tab s8 ultra but before we do
that i want to look over the results for
wild rift first of all we had perfect
60fps on the tab which is awesome
especially since the graphics were
excellent and unfortunately for some
reason it was showing 120 fps recorded
on the ipad pro when in reality the fps
counter showed below 120 like 115 110
sometimes even as low as 90 fps so for
some reason this was not reliable it was
not as solid as this all right now that
we're in game let's go ahead and start
that recording notice a little bit of
glitchiness there let's go into the
graphic settings let's just turn it up
as much as we can so it looks like we're
capped to 60 and everything else is
turned on perfect wow
that is so beautiful and immersive
however i am noticing some anti-aliasing
like it's just not that sharp
looking at the details now looking over
at the fps counter we are currently
sitting at around what is that 55.50 how
is it now oh 40 48 right there so it's
not solid 60 like it was on those other
games let's do some flying and oh 44.
when you have all this stuff going on it
definitely dips down 40 and you do
notice some stuttering some glitching
not all 30
is that 35 what is going on look we're
averaging around 40 right now and i
could feel it
oh
now i don't feel the back of this thing
heating up at all this is a very large
tablet so it has a lot of chassis to
disperse the heat but i'm not happy with
how much it stutters sometimes just
random frame drops during gameplay
that's what i would call probably the
most annoying thing while you're gaming
is just to have like a glitch where it
just stutters
and the fps just drops randomly right
with that said
decent gameplay very immersive display
but in this game we did get a lot of
frame drops down to around 40 so that's
not what you want to see
if you're a gention impact gamer let's
move over to the ipad pro here we are
again in the graphics settings and now
as you can see the ipad pro has a 120
fps setting that is so exciting and
awesome for people who like to game on
tablets and play genshin
and
the difference is
absolutely massive i mean that thing was
stuttering fps was below 60 almost all
the time and it even went down to 40 but
this right here
this is going to be interesting this
time it looks like the fps is reacting
correctly like we just dipped down
during that travel now we're looking at
around 118. already i can see
a massive oh my goodness this is awesome
a massive difference now that is what
makes the ipad pro just so nice because
you have awesome awesome software
support
allowing you to get 120fps in a lot of
games now i am noticing every once in a
while it does drop the frame rate a
little bit and it does have a little bit
of a stutter but i think it's maintained
over 60
the entire time which is very impressive
because this thing i mean went down to
40.
boom
i'm happy with this guys
i think i've seen everything i need to
see and there you guys go that was
gentian impact on both of these tablets
and before i show you guys the average
fps results for both of the tablets i
want to show you guys the difference in
brightness comparing mini led and the
oled so watch this
there's that and here it is maxed out on
this guy
done done and as you can see in the top
camera the ipad pro is quite a bit
brighter than the tab s8 ultra and of
course you don't get all of these wavy
pwm lines on the ipad pro but let's get
to these results first off we have the
tab s8 ultra clocking in
52.1 fps average throughout that gentian
impact test
you can see there's these
frame drops right here
all over the place so that's very
interesting and then going down to the
cpu usage we're at 47.1
average cpu usage very interesting and
let's see the ipad pro
boom
113.8
fps average on the ipad pro
that is absolutely insane basically two
times better and you can see that you're
not getting all those massive drops and
issues like the other one was having
going down the cpu oh my goodness
only 15.2
cpu usage what how does that even make
sense that's crazy compared to the 47 so
obviously the ipad pro is a much better
device for gunshin impact and now
finally let me give you guys my
conclusions first of all the massive
display on the tab is awesome i'm sure
it's great for media consumption and
it's just so immersive in terms of the
gameplay but in some of the games the
actual display was so big that i don't
know the scaling or something wasn't as
good and i think the resolution is lower
than the ipad pro in terms of the pixels
per inch so the display isn't as high
quality and of course you have the pwm
lines that could annoy some people and
also the speakers on the ipad pro were
better more boomy in terms of the bass
now in terms of the performance if
you're okay with just playing at 60fps
then the tab is fine for most games you
get the bigger display which is very
nice but in genshin it couldn't even
handle a solid 60. it went down to 40
many times for some reason
so
if you want the best fps i mean like
almost all those games that we played
gave us a 120fps option on the ipad pro
that is absolutely amazing and it was
able to keep up with 120 in almost all
the games i think it was a wild rift
where it went down to 90 at times but
still so much better than being locked
to 60. so with all of that said
i'm honestly gonna give the win to the
ipad pro it is still the best gaming
tablet out there especially because of
the 120fps so hopefully you guys enjoy
this gaming comparison if you did go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and check out our other comparisons
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]